welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fair and cousin sitting in for David
Pakman today you know on Wednesday a lot
of us were surprised to see Donald Trump
tweet out his goodbyes really to White
House councilor Don Magan Trump tweeted
out the following here White House
Counsel Don Magan will be leaving his
position in the fall shortly after the
confirmation hopefully of Judge Brett
Kavanaugh to the United States Supreme
Court I have worked with Don for a long
time and truly appreciate his service
now most of us who saw the tweet when it
happened thought oh okay Don Magan
resigned you know he decided he's gonna
move on he's gonna go do something else
but either way it was a little shocking
but you know who it was even more
shocking for Don Magan because the man
had no idea that he was going to be
leaving the administration sometime in
the fall shortly after Brett Kavanaugh
was confirmation hopefully he was just
as shocked as we were to learn that he
was I guess resigning from the
administration and he also yes learned
about it through Donald Trump's tweets
there's a lot to really unpack from such
a simple sounding story here there is a
reason obviously Donald Trump has
decided to part ways with Don Magan we
learned last week that Magan has been
working with special prosecutor Robert
Muller as is his responsibility to do so
and that Trump seemed to think that
McGann's job was to work for him when in
reality it's to work for the office of
the presidency more of the position than
the person to protect the dignity and
integrity of the office of the
presidency not the person who happens to
hold that title so if Trump believed
that McGann was his personal attorney
it's very likely that McGann knows all
of the dirty secrets that Trump has to
offer but the fact that McGann had been
meeting with Muller and cooperating with
him and I believe he had ended up
sitting down for 30 hours worth of
discussions or testimony or whatever it
was
yeah probably didn't make Donald Trump
too happy then of course there are the
reports from earlier in this week that
said that the White House lawyers which
includes Don McGann were the ones who
were preventing Donald Trump from firing
Jeff sessions and thereby firing Robert
Muller well Trump took offense to that
he didn't want people to think that Don
McGann had any power here in the White
House or that he was over there telling
Muller a bunch of secrets so he did the
cowardly thing and decided to fire him
at an unspecified date sometime in the
fall without bothering to tell him in
person first now as you'll recall this
is actually not the first person from
the Trump administration to be fired via
Twitter but it does make you wonder this
man became famous really for the first
time actually famous by going on and
hosting a reality TV show where he would
famously fire people to their faces
you're fired
sure everybody remembers that but now
now that the cameras aren't rolling
around him now that there's not script
writers and producers he's suddenly too
terrified to actually fire people to
their face he has to do it via Twitter I
mean what if Don McGann wasn't on
Twitter that day what if he doesn't
follow the president what if he's one of
the people the president still had block
how is he gonna know he's fired does he
just have to wait and watch it on cable
news and hope that somebody else
mentions it Trump is a coward absolutely
100% if you want to fire somebody go
ahead and do it you don't have to get on
social media and tell the world first
and wait for the person to sit there and
hear word that oh I've been canned
I guess I'll pack my stuff oh oh I have
until the fall what the hell is going on
that's essentially the slogan for this
White House at this point what the hell
is going on that's what we're living
with right now the other part of the
story let's assume obviously Don McGann
is gonna be leaving
okay Trump then gets to replace him how
horrible is that going to be for the
president
this man has proven time and time again
that he picks the absolute worst people
to surround himself with you know when
we look at Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson was really really bad and then
after he fired him we get Mike Pompeo
who is so much worse than Rex Tillerson
Pompeo leaves the CIA so he replaces him
with Geena Haspel the woman who helped
revolutionize torture in the Bush
administration we've seen from his own
personal lawyers that he's hired Jay
Sekulow Rudy Giuliani Ty Cobb really not
the sharpest legal minds out there in
this country that were available to help
him so who is he gonna replace McGann
with I mean who out there is going to
want to take this position first and
foremost because that's really important
you know that the president is just
going to beat up on you all day and that
he just wants somebody to come into that
position that is going to protect him
not just the office of the presidency
and that specific role in our government
he's gonna want somebody that's gonna be
his Lackey he's gonna want a toad he's
gonna be once somebody who's gonna do
whatever he tells them to do and that's
what he's gonna pick and as we've seen
time and time again any time he goes for
somebody that checks off to all those
little Mark's it's the worst possible
person imaginable and it always ends
very badly for Donald Trump what's gonna
happen when he replaces McGann with
somebody who says yeah you know what
maybe you should just go fire jeff
Sessions I don't care
maybe you should fire a robert muller
that seems like a good idea there's
going to be massive public backlash
there's going to be replacements that
come in that are even more incompetent
than the ones we have there in terms of
Jeff Sessions and with Muller he's still
going to have to reappoint a new special
prosecutor that has to finish the job
not to mention the fact that all of
those process
solutions that Muller has been farming
out and now there's actually speculation
that he may already have sealed cases
resting with judges that we don't even
know about yet in case he gets fired
molars crossed his T's and dotted his
eyes and he's got his parachute ready he
knows that if he gets fired these
prosecutions this investigation is not
going to end he's covered every single
possible base to make sure that the
investigation survives even if his
position with it
doesn't so Donald Trump is in for a
world of hurt
because he doesn't know what he's doing
as president but he thinks that anyone
who comes into the Oval Office or
anywhere in the White House really
should be loyal to him and nothing else